Welcome to "English in a Minute",...
...where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
We have some phrases that sound a little painful, like this one:...
...I am going to bite my tongue.
This does not sound good, like it might hurt.
Let's listen again.
I couldn't believe that happened!
I know.
Are you going to say something?
No, I am going to bite my tongue.
I can't believe you are not going to say something.
In American English, if I say that I'm going to bite my tongue,...
...it means that I won't talk about something.
I am going to keep quiet.
This is an informal phrase, not one for business.
I am going to bite my tongue.
And that's "English in a Minute".